hey everyone thanks for listening it's
me rayne wilson and i'm reza aslan hi
everyone hello hello reza i've got
something on my mind
it's it's about airbud isn't it it's uh
all you think about is airbud i agree
with you it is
a franchise that never really got its
due
we all agree there you don't have to
keep bringing it up every show
okay
yes airbud is
a classic
but i was thinking a little bit more
about racism
oh
okay what about racism racism sucks
reza
wow it's so bad
that's a deep dude this did very
controversial statement here from rayne
wilson you heard it right here it is
awful
just the worst
take it easy take it easy rain
you don't want to get too political i
know how you feel about that
it's just terrible
look of course it's terrible i'm a brown
man from iran i'm a muslim like i know
what racism is like i you should i
should show you the files
of racist uh hate that i get for me and
and my family yes racism is bad i know
that well not yet not only that i mean
yeah you're
you've you've undergone a little bit i
mean imagine how bad it is for african
americans here in america it's just yes
it's the worst but you know what where
it really hits home
is with people like me the whities
us whites
i've been pondering this
racism has so adversely affected white
people's pocketbooks
over the last several hundred years it's
just horrific i have a very poor family
dare i say white trash i mean without
racism in this country we would probably
have health care
um my family would um
universal health care we would probably
have free college education
there would be
better wages and salaries stronger
unions
except for
racism which has really
really [ __ ] up
me and my white brothers and sisters
well now this is this is actually pretty
deep brain i i was just getting ready to
make fun of you for talking about how
bad racism has been for you as a white
man so bad but you couldn't even
understand
but you're actually right about this
that obvi you know obviously we talk
about how racism is terrible for people
who are literally
uh the target of racism and racist
attacks
but what we don't talk about enough
is how racism is bad for everyone else
every single person on the planet now
before we get everyone hanging up on our
podcast and pissed off at me this is the
point because
we have read an extraordinary book
and uh we are going to be talking with
an extraordinary author
and why don't you tell them a little bit
about that yep in fact uh we have a
guest here her name is heather mcgee
she's a wonderful brilliant thinker um
she is a political commentator she was a
a political strategist she's a former
president of a think tank called deimos
which
creates policy proposals progressive
policy proposals she's uh
you know a commentator and she's written
this book that you just kind of talked
about a minute ago called the sum of us
which
you know i'm gonna rain and i are
obsessed with this book we're obsessed
with this book right and the sum of us
and the subtitle is what racism costs
everyone and how we can prosper
together it's an incredible way forward
for all of us
in america and she's a self-described
policy nerd and economics wonk she loves
like
budgets and policies and legislation and
yet this book is so insightful and just
eminently readable and relatable it has
huge heart and we thought let's have her
on the show
to you know help us figure out how we
end racism as we know it let's have her
solve racism this has been
a thorn in the side of america
and a
a shoe in the face of america for
hundreds of years maybe heather mcgee
can solve racism
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
hello mcgee hi
hey
uh heather is my friend rayne unlike you
you have
i'm surprised you have a a friend rezab
but listen heather
welcome to the milkshake
if this was
if this was like an early morning am
like rock jock
welcome to the milkshake
righteous rain and
and rutabaga reza in the house
let's fix racism y'all
racism
victory says i'm gonna fix racism
you know we would probably have more
audience actually if that were there
that's true
speaking of audience what i mean huge
success the book is called the sum of us
i
love
this book and you know what i was going
to read it anyway
because like we're friends and i feel
like i'm going to buy it i'm going to
read it anyway and then i would like
normally in these situations pretend
that i liked it and be like really
fascinating but like
ask rayne honestly halfway through the
book i called him and i was like i
[ __ ] love this book yes
of all the books we've read so far this
was the one that warranted like four
uh offline discussions about how great
this book was and how yes you know it's
oddly for all of this policy stuff and
you call yourself a policy nerd and a
policy walk like it's oddly moving like
it just touched my heart
so many times in in a very
different way um
and just thrilled to talk to you about
it because
uh essentially you've solved racism so
um this is this is great news america
best part of it ladies and gentlemen
here we go
the end of racism go heather go
oh my god i love this so much i love
this so much well i
do think there's a path i cannot say
that having sold you know a few tens of
thousands of books has quite
accomplished the goal but i do think
there's a path i took a journey over the
course of three years all across the
country talk to hundreds of people and i
see a path well maybe the paperback i
think the paperback is cheaper there we
go more likely to solve racism than that
it's gonna reach the millions that we
need to reach um so
let's start with the central metaphor
of the book
you talk about how
white folk have repeatedly
via racism shot themselves in the
economic foot
and the uh
the
it's not an analogy it's not a simile
what is it it's not even really it is
somewhat metaphoric but the example that
you use frankly is the shutting down of
the swimming pools so
in the late 50s there was great uh
economic success in post-war america the
eisenhower years etc and
america especially in the south decided
to build beautiful parks and beautiful
swimming pools and they were gigantic
olympic-sized pools and parks uh
everywhere and then but black people
weren't allowed of course because this
was the jim crow south and then when
that got to the courts the court said
well you're gonna have to let black
people into these beautiful swimming
pools and they did and it was great
the end bye everybody
and so what happened is just
um uh flat i'm gonna i'm to date myself
here it was flabbergasting i was
flabbergasted my jaw dropped
time and time again throughout the south
especially montgomery alabama and many
other places the swimming pools were
bulldozed in they were filled in with
dirt the parks were closed entire parks
departments were shuttered and shut down
like literally like let's no longer have
a parks department in this town or in
this county or even in this state and
playgrounds were shut down zoos were
shut down the animals were were sold and
given away because white people were so
racist they did not want to share their
parks their zoos and their swimming
pools with black folk and here you have
this incredible searing example
of white people cutting off their nose
to spite their face that um
they would give up beautiful parks and
recreation and family time and really
hurt
um
socially hurt what's the word i'm
looking for
not socially what is it um
well it tore at the fabric of the
community too yeah it hurt the fabric of
the community to not have these
beautiful kind of civic programs in
place all because of of racism and this
set us back
decades i mean us
white folk to lump myself in with these
white folk of that era back decades and
and really [ __ ] us up and um this has
happened time and time again so can you
tell us a little bit about
why this happened with the swimming
pools and what i'm leading you toward is
this whole
zero-sum racism that you talk about
i mean i wish it was just fools right i
mean i'm an economic policy person so i
wish i could say hey it's nice you know
that people swim or don't swim it
doesn't really matter but the drained
pool began to stand in for me as
an allegory
for that's the word i was looking for
heather allegory
who was allegory the whole time
i mean i don't know it may be parable
right maybe limerick i'm not sure like
yeah but there once was a man from
montgomery who wanted to pull swim in a
pool and so he could hummery and he he
dove in the dirt and there was no pool
and everyone laughed and white people
were very very sad
rain doesn't really know how limericks
work but yeah something like that
sorry go ahead um please please continue
with this central haiku of your
of your book
five syllables the drained public pool
okay that's as far as they're gonna go
the trade public pool um
really stands in to help explain what
happened to a whole host of public goods
and protections that the government used
to really have a strong commitment to in
this country think about the massive
expansion of working-class people being
able to afford a home because of
subsidies and housing think about social
security think about the gi bill which
made college free for a generation of
gis and all of that either explicitly or
implicitly excluded most black people
just like the pools and what i found was
that if you try to explain what happened
to the like great american dream the
great middle class the aussie and
harriet the you know it was basically
easy to have a really great standard of
living we had the highest standard of
living in the world and then what
happened starting in the late 70s and
80s where it suddenly became this
inequality economy right what an economy
that used to look like a football with a
fatter middle and and and smaller
numbers of high and low income people
then look like a bow tie with a shrunken
middle and a lot more poor people and a
lot more very rich people like what
happened i know what happened in terms
of you know what would change in taxes
and labor but why
and really the drained pool helps
explain how it was
that the majority of white americans
turned their backs on the formula that
had created the middle class that had
given nice things to millions of people
in a public freeway and instead made
them a private cost and a private luxury
right like some white families could
still swim even when they gutted the
parks and recreation department because
they just built a backyard pool or they
had these membership-only private swim
clubs and that's sort of like what our
society is today right like if you can
afford it you can have the nice things
in life but if you're on the edge or if
you're even just solidly middle class
these things like child care and health
care and housing and
college have been priced out of reach
because we've turned our backs on the
idea that there are some things that
should be public goods and it really was
racism and the idea of sharing those
things across lines of race that was the
the catalyst for this monumental
political shift that white people had in
the wake of the civil rights movement
sort of over to the right wing so uh
it's like turning racism into a zero-sum
game so for people like rain who don't
understand what zero-sum game means uh
it essentially means that i had to
google it but
he did that
totally i'm a pretty smart guy that's
what google is for and and i people talk
about oh it's a zero-sum game joe some
game i'm like i always knob my head yes
sounds like a zero-sum game what does
this mean
okay listeners at home
who are ignorant like me it means games
where
there's uh there's a has to be a loser
if there's a winner so if the numbers go
up there has to be a corresponding
numbers going down so that always equals
zero which means basically there's not a
scenario in which all boats float
upwards that's right in terms of racism
it essentially means that
that the white person's prosperity must
come at the expense of um the someone
else of of of a different race right
that that improving the status of a
racial minority
necessarily means worsening the status
of white people which even as i say it i
mean it's like it's absurd it's one of
those one of those statements where like
the idiocy of it is baked into the
sentence itself and yet heather and yet
[Music]
folks let's get real
we can all probably use a lot more
fruits and veggies in our diet i mean
it's not the easiest thing to do
especially
like me when you're either like working
at home and you just eat whatever's in
the fridge or like you know you stop at
a
drive-through on the way home from work
and i don't know about you but i have
made it my resolution to change that and
that's why i'm keeping my freezer
stocked with daily harvest daily harvest
is the easiest way to get more fruits
and veggies into my day every day they
have my back with delicious food that's
good for me and it's good for the planet
this household i'm telling you rain we
are all about the daily harvest we like
we have we have i think more than one
daily harvest subscription in this
household that's a lot
more than one is a lot yes
that's that's like two or more
that's that is yes that is what uh two
or more means and and i know that
because i eat my fruits and vegetables
yes you do reza and you know i love the
daily harvest uh i keep many in my
freezer
um i love it you know they they have
these great oat
uh bowls oh yeah for the breakfast yeah
the food and there's like oats with like
mangoes and berries and you just like
you add some water and heat it right up
and it's just nutritious
and try to like add a little bit of warm
milk to it that's what i did and they've
got great like snacks lunches dinners
whatever you want to do there's
smoothies big fan of the smoothies
they've got a whole line of smoothies
they've got these harvest bowls broccoli
and cheese harvest bowl is one of my
very favorites what we're saying folks
is that daily harvest makes it easy for
you to feel good
about what you're doing for yourself and
for your planet so go to
dailyharvest.com
milkshake to get up to 40 bucks off your
first box that's dailyharvest.com
milkshake for up to 40 off your first
box dailyharvest.com milkshake who knows
maybe you too will have more than one
subscription you know what folks flowers
are sweet but she'd prefer to sleep
show you care by giving your valentine
the gift of better sleep and wellness
from cbdistillery.com
no seriously with all that's gone on in
the world these last couple of years a
special valentine's day assortment of
cbd products is an exceptionally
thoughtful gift for that special someone
the potential health benefits of cbd are
impressive from better sleep to less
worry and more calm i can't think of a
better valentine's day gift with over 2
million subscribers
and with over 2 million customers cb
distillery is the source to trust for
safe effective and natural cbd products
and you never need a prescription at
cbdistillery.com
so show your valentine how thoughtful
you are and how much you care with a
sweet gift assortment of cbd products
from cbdistillery.com
and be sure to use promo code love for
20 off again that's promo code love
cbdistillery.com again that's promo code
love cbdistillery.com
[Music]
and yet the first study that i read at
the start of this journey to write this
book was called whites now see racism as
a zero-sum game that they are now losing
which was this study
um which looked at from these two
boston-based professors which asked a
whole bunch of white people uh kind of
to to to evaluate on a one to ten scale
how much racism there was against black
people versus white people and they
rated anti-white racism as more
prominent more serious than anti-black
racism this is in the middle of obama's
first term as president and they said it
was basically
because
they had seen
black people get more positions of power
more people of color in the country and
so in the zero sum logic that must mean
that whites were now the discriminated
class and then if you look at a whole
other set of research that's related um
it's this idea of a group status threat
right when you ask white people
um you know if you show them the fact
that they will soon be the majority
it will soon be a quote-unquote majority
minority country that that the
demographic changes are happening and so
there will be no racial majority in 2042
or whatever the year is
that
that makes them
more conservative on issues that
nominally have nothing to do with race
from the minimum wage to drilling in the
arctic it's sort of this sense of like
we know what it is to be a minority on a
gut level we don't want to be a minority
and so we want to sort of extract and
hoard all the resources we can from the
status quo um because we're afraid of a
future in which we no longer have this
status advantage okay i love i love this
because i have to admit i was listening
to your uh uh book on tape i was
listening to your lovely voice speaking
to me at 1.5 speed because you know i
mean you're you're kind of a slow reader
um and
wow while i was driving my family in a
gigantic rv and uh and i'm listening oh
here he goes here he goes with the rv
story
guess what heather it broke down in
fresno tell us again about your
adventure basically technically it broke
down in vacaville but which is vacaville
i mean fresno
thank you for taking care of us um
and i got to this part that you were
mentioning like yes okay so this
narrative that um white people
uh see
the well-being of people of color as a
threat to their own
um well-being uh that's crazy and we're
gonna talk a ton more about that
but early in the book you talk about
what you just mentioned which i mean
almost i almost drove off drove off a
cliff uh when i when i heard this
when you
um
explain any kind of policy proposal
by making either race or demographic
changes a salient point in that policy
proposal
what happens is that white people
regardless of whether they are
republican or democrat regardless of
whether they are liberal or conservative
are more likely
to take the conservative republican
position on that proposal so
in other words like if you if you say to
people college should be free you know
people on the right disagree people on
the left uh tend to agree if you say
college should be free because people of
color have been historically
uh left out of you know higher education
the white people regardless of whether
they're on the left or right are more
likely to disagree with the concept that
college should be free am i am i saying
that right
yeah pretty much pretty much um
basically
you know in some ways this is
kind of taken
it it both requires all of these this
study and it's sort of jaw-dropping to
see it laid out
and yet it is the core logic that is
animated and in fact curtailed the
policy ambition of democrats
for my entire career right the idea that
if we talk about race if we do things
that will help people at the bottom of
the social hierarchy whether they're
very poor or they're black and brown or
because they're very poor white voters
assume they're black and brown that is
going to alienate some white suburban
moderate and therefore we either
shouldn't do the policy or shouldn't
talk about it or probably both so you're
talking about it that's been so funny
sorry to interrupt but heather you're
talking about race and class like you
can't bring up race or class
in policy
decisions or in educating the public
about policy because that will turn
the average suburban housewife in st
louis against the idea
is that right well you can talk about
class in some ways but once you start
talking about poverty and people who are
poor
that so reads in the white imagination
as black even though the largest share
of impoverished people are white right
um but but the media skews it right
there have been a lot of studies about
the sort of face of poverty in the news
media which is far more likely to be
black than it is in the actual
population so
yes
poverty um
crime
and actually talking about people of
color all of that sort of reads in the
white imagination as talking about
people of color and because
that identity has been so degraded and
by that i mean the sense that
people of color if they're in a you know
economic struggle
it's because of bad choices that they
made
not because being paid too little
or not having enough good paying jobs
and having high unemployment rates or
being the subject of discrimination has
made them has given them poor choices
like between rent and food right so
there's this sense of blaming the victim
that is really core to
the politics of the past 40 to 50 years
and it has meant that your typical white
voter is more conservative than they
would have been before
uh the civil rights act and then they
were before we had more diversity in
this country
and they're more conservative in their
voting patterns than they should be to
meet their basic needs issues like the
unaffordability of college is something
i talk about as an example of racism
draining the pool
college used to be free
when it was 95
plus people going to college who were
white and this anti-government ethos
that sprung up really after the
government moved from being the enforcer
of the racial hierarchy right and the
segregator to the upbender of the racial
hierarchy and the civil rights movement
most white americans turned their backs
on government and felt like it was a
betrayal and and began to distrust
collective action and began to prefer
tax cuts and the market to the
government and so what did that mean it
meant that there was less of a political
voting bloc for
maintaining public spending on college
and you had the draining of the pool 26
cents on the dollar on average state
schools cutting their funding shifting
into tuition now we've got a system
where we have a trillion and a half
dollars in student debt and the reason
why i say that's
like draining the pool is that meant
that working in middle class white
people also have to borrow to go to
college black people have to borrow more
right black people never got to swim but
white people who are not very wealthy
are struggling as well and that's where
the opening is for a race conscious
cross-racial class solidarity to to
emerge in this country and frankly i
think it is okay one thing that i
thought was really fascinating about
this is that
people of color
don't
see
race as zero sum right that stat after
stat shows that while you know white
people tend to see
racism as zero-sum people of color don't
like people of color don't think oh well
like if a white person succeeds that
means that i can't
what's that about why
yeah um
you know that's that's it's interesting
because we're just better people
it was that racist that was that was
racist no
no
no it wasn't racist it was
uh it was stereotyping um
uh but
and it was you know evalu you know
judging people based on color but if you
add a little more sophistication to what
you're saying reza it might be totally a
fun thing to say right
so everything we believe comes from a
story that we've been told and so
when i think about you know how you can
possibly talk about majorities of white
people believing certain things and
having sort of shared consciousness and
way of looking at the world and how you
can distinguish those from people who
have heard been told a different story
by society because of their culture and
because of um the importance of
who is telling the story
i almost think about it as like the
white story it's not about the white
race because race doesn't exist right
it's a social contract
rain and i may have more genetically in
common than i have in common with you
know
ice cube or someone like that right um
who you know there there is a really
important distinction to make between
the stories we're told and the stories
we believe
about our identity and about other
people's identity
and what i'm trying to do in the sum of
us is remind people that
all of these stories that we believe
about ourselves about who we are to one
another about our relative status and
relative worth
are being told
by often like a pretty
concentrated narrow self-interested
elite who is selling the story of
zero-sum racism and zero-sun racial
hierarchy to white audiences and they're
doing it for their own profit and so it
has served an economic interest to have
white people prefer to see themselves
as better than people of color who may
even be similarly situated
so that they can sort of divide the
working and middle class and this divide
and conquer strategy is older than the
nation it is one of the first sort of
things that the colonial elite did in
order to maintain
racial slavery and to convince the
masses of white people who were here in
servitude that they were somehow better
than african slaves and frankly get them
to defend
slavery
which was nonetheless
enslaving these white people out of a
job right
enslaved black people were
not slaver was not in the near-term
immediate economic interest of white
indentured servants in the pre-american
days and the colonial days um
and yet as a response to cross-racial
uprisings among
servants who were white black and
indigenous
the elite created a difference and said
hey white people side with your race
instead of your class
and that's what conservative race
mongers are doing today and for the same
goal to make sure that the economic
elite has the buy-in of the mass of
white people
[Music]
rain did you know that only nine percent
of plastic actually gets recycled no
matter how much you put in your
recycling bin
wow
at grove collaborative they believe it's
time to ditch single-use plastics for
good grove carries hundreds of products
aimed at replacing single-use plastics
across your home and personal care
routine and by 2025 grove itself will be
100 plastic free
like concentrated cleaners and
refillable glass bottles they're
friendlier to the planet and twice as
effective as the leading natural brands
switch to sustainable products for every
room in your home from laundry care to
hand soaps and more grove co
has you covered with safe formulas and
refillable packaging that never
compromise on performance this is we're
in our household we're all about the
growth because like we made a our 2022
new year's resolution was less plastic
that was our family resolution
and so i mean this is like
right up our alley we are we definitely
are part of the two million households
that are already shopping sustainably at
grove and you can be too so go to
grove.com milkshake today to get a free
gift set worth up to 50 dollars with
your first order plus shipping is fast
and free get started right now at
grove.com
milkshake grove.com
milkshake
nordvpn is a secure way of preventing
your personal information from being
spread all around the web and the dark
web when using wi-fi the line of
protection is wonderful it prevents spam
viruses and other unwanted privacy
intruders
reza do you like nordvpn yeah i actually
uh use nordvpn for a whole host of
things like when i'm you know at
airports or whatever and i'm using wi-fi
that i can't trust i also actually use
it
to
uh access like libraries around the
world because you know i'm a i'm a smart
serious man and i'm constantly trying to
access libraries around the world and uh
and yeah nord allows me to do that and
listen if you're not a smart serious man
you can also use nordvpn to access
entertainment content from all around
the world 59 countries
to be exact simply by changing your
virtual location with a single click i
mean you know rain you and me we live in
the u.s but with nordvpn we can be
anywhere in the world and we can access
content from all those regions
that's right you can even use nordvpn on
up to six devices your laptop phone ipad
smart tv etc
i love to use nordvpn to access my
favorite tv shows in other countries as
reza was talking about so go to
nordvpn.com milkshake or use code
milkshake to get up to 70 off your
nordvpn plan
plus one additional month for free it's
also risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee
and if you two are like me you know you
carry your
ipad or your
you know laptop all around with you to
like coffee shops and restaurants and
bars and you're just like constantly
getting on people's wi-fi you don't know
where that wi-fi has been people
you don't know who's listening
[Music]
so
i love i love what you're saying so much
and i love this whole idea of the white
story um
i had an aha moment that happened about
20 years ago
and i always consider myself a little
bit more on the woke spectrum than not
but i used to um a great deal listen to
am
right wing radio and i was driving
through los angeles i just moved here
and i was listening to i don't know rush
limbaugh or someone like that and the
the point of the story was they found a
black woman in detroit
who had won the lottery and won like
three million dollars and then they
found that she was also taking welfare
of like
i don't know 200 a week or something
like that and that she had been taking
welfare for
a year and a half or something like that
and call after call of outrage about
this woman
and
it just went on it this wasn't like a
little news piece like oh let's talk
about this for four minutes and then get
on i mean it was fully an hour long
about talking about this woman who'd won
the lottery
and i was driving along i was like what
is happening here i'm trying to wrap my
head around this discussion like what's
what's the dog whistle you know as they
always say what's the story behind the
story well the story is obviously that
these very canny kind of right-wing news
folk have figured out how to poke this
beehive and foment outrage by saying
here's this black woman who and they
didn't go into like was it negligence
did she forget to quit her welfare was
were she was she really like drawing and
and who cares anyway she was caught she
paid the 13 000 back to the government
or or whatever it was but there is so
much going on in the world to be
concerned about and yet there was this
hour of outrage over this woman and
that's when it really hit me like a ton
of bricks oh i see this is all about
race this is all about perpetuating this
white story
which is that
um
these black and brown people are sucking
your tax dollars away and the government
is essentially corrupt and is playing
into this whole
into this whole story and
and
so let's get rid of welfare
so and this was you know and this was
uh was it clinton or post clinton
but it was
let's get rid of welfare years and this
drew me to um a quote that
you had as a in in your book and there's
a famous quote by lee atwater who
people may know was a a very famous uh
republican strategist um it worked for
for bush and and others and he was taped
saying you start out in 1954 by saying n
word n word n word he wasn't saying n
word he was saying the actual word by
1968 you can't say n-word
that hurts you backfires so you say
stuff like forced busing states rights
all that stuff and you're getting
abstract and then you're cut talking
about cutting taxes and all of these
you're talking about these totally
economic things he said there's a quote
and a byproduct of them is that blacks
get hurt worse than whites so
you know this
maybe this is kind of racism 101 but
you know when you go to the swimming
pool analogy and i think about the woman
in detroit who won the lottery and you
think about this white story
um
it's it's been so cannily played
um
to
the um well to the advantage of wealthy
white people like that's the thing what
i love about the story that you just
told rain is that
it it's like it's so perfect like it's
it's it's like gift wrapped right
so therefore let's get rid of
um welfare which
overwhelmingly helps white poor people
like the the majority of white how many
white people reign you know this like
what's the percentage of white people
who are on welfare uh it's welfare uh
recipients are in the high 40s so almost
half are on uh welfare and then it's
like
25 30 right so it's like it's like i
think it's a quintessential version of
you know what heather's talking about
with with zero-sum racism
yeah you know and
i think there's two pieces there
that i think are really important to
underscore one who was saying that it
was rush limbaugh a straight-up
millionaire right who is paid to peddle
this hate right um you know tucker
carlson is today's version donald trump
rupert murdoch the one pulling the
strings for a bunch of this right these
are all millionaires and billionaires
who are these paid bullies using the
corporate media to divide working people
from one another
and
i think there's sort of like a deeper
kind of fascinating
thing that i touch on a little bit in
the book but
to get to the metaphysical milkshake
part of this i was thinking about
the the insistence
that in fact it's black people who are
getting something for free from the
government
when
it's
not true today
and it was even less true
[Music]
for all of our history
and this brings up the psychological
sort of
framework known as projection
right in order to maintain your vision
of yourself as a good person
you often
project your own negative you know
naturally we all have good and bad
things about us qualities on to the
racialized other that's some of the work
that race does it it sort of creates
this shadow that you can project all of
these things onto right and
in the book um on page 47 in fact people
have sort of said it to me enough that i
remember what page it is i go through
the list of free stuff that white people
got from the government in order to
create the kind of intergenerational
wealth that even some of the poorest
white americans have today over some of
the richest black americans right like
the the average white high school
dropout has more wealth like home equity
savings some stocks and bonds somewhere
than the average black college graduate
right so this is about history showing
you up in your wallet and where what is
this history it's a history of free
stuff being given by the government from
like the homestead act which was
literally
acres of free land to any family for the
cost of a filing fee it was taken from
indigenous people and given to white
people for free through to all the
things i talked about in the new deal
through to the gi bill um this massive
subsidization of housing which is really
like the quintessential how you have
economic security in america it's the
linchpin of the american dream
basically
for free in a way that deliberately
excluded black people from being able to
participate in mortgages and and
subsidized housing
and so what do you do with all that like
what do you do with the knowledge of
that i think most white people don't
know it
right like to their credit they actually
are
actually ignorant of the degree to which
government privileged white people over
everybody else but to then
after
just a few short years of the civil
rights movement to say that it's
actually government
that is
favoring black people over all others is
this massive projection
and
i just wonder on a sort of metaphysical
level why that's important
what work that is doing to us as a
society
um and
and i think it's really important to be
able to punch through it if we're ever
going to have people who see themselves
in one another and aren't so easily
manipulated by the scapegoating so this
this then is the fundamental conclusion
the inevitable conclusion of zero-sum
racism which is that everyone loses and
that's really
the the the driving force of of the book
and there's a ton of examples that we
can we can talk about you've already
mentioned uh a bunch of them
um certainly you know health care um
voting rights um the housing crisis like
all of these
problems that we are facing
have as at their heart um this issue of
zero-sum racism where it's like well if
this is going to benefit people of color
then we don't want to have anything to
do with it even though it means that
everyone is going to end up suffering as
a result but i was thinking to myself
what
better example
like
immediate current example
of the way that zero-sum racism
results in everyone getting [ __ ] then
the government's response to coronavirus
right yeah i mean i remember so clearly
when you know jared kushner that [ __ ]
douchebag
who was like this is a california and
new york problem you know exactly what
he meant
by that don't you
you know exactly what he meant when that
[ __ ] says poorly run democratic cities
exactly he was talking about black and
brown people that's what he was talking
about it's their problem and then now of
course like everyone in south dakota is
dying of covid
right right i mean it's like it it never
ends the cycle just seems to continue
um
i was thinking like
i we we've we kind of we can talk about
the the sort of the top 10 greatest hits
of of situations in which we've all kind
of you know been [ __ ] as a result of
zero-sum racism
uh but are there are there like lesser
known ones i wonder like are there ones
that maybe you wouldn't normally think
about
um when you when you sort of think about
like all the problems that we're facing
now
yeah so i didn't set out to write about
climate change in the environment um
it's not my area of expertise most of
the chapters about the economy there's
one big chapter about democracy because
i was democracy rights advocate as well
but
you know once i started seeing the
fingerprints of every of racism
everywhere in our collective dysfunction
to solve problems i was like well what
about the big kahuna here what about our
unwillingness and inability to stop a
meteor from coming towards the earth
when we're supposed to be superman like
why aren't we suiting up like what is
the problem with this country we're
responsible for most of the carbon in
the air with a world leader why are we
not doing this particularly when it
could be such a win-win right the vision
of
transforming our economy and innovating
on new forms of energy and just having
this like exciting new world war ii
mobilization moment like it feels so
quintessentially american to be like
we're gonna lead on this and yet we keep
not doing it
and then i started to ask questions i in
some ways wish that i hadn't asked about
why it is that our country alone among
the industrialized world the
conservative faction in our country not
only
oh maybe wants to do market-based
solutions to control you know carbon
pollution is flat out denying that
there's a problem and wants to sort of
double down in the other direction
and then it
you know occurs to me again that that
conservative faction is overwhelmingly
white and more likely to be male and i
was like so is there some white male
thing going on with climate denialism
like what is the deal
and that's when i started asking around
and asking climate sociologists and
people in the you know environmental
movement and it turns out that there is
a correlation between the
the white story that particularly white
men have been
told about the social hierarchy which is
basically
there's sort of this natural hierarchy
of value among human beings and there's
a ladder and the people on top are kind
of on top because they're better they're
stronger they're fitter they're better
and when when the water is rising right
um if there is a risk generally speaking
white men tend to minimize the idea of
the risk because they think well i'm
going to be protected by it and the
people who are going to be vulnerable to
it are them that like have made bad
choices and put themselves in that
position or sort of weaker
whether it's like you know global south
nations or people in
in the united states and so there's this
idea that
it's like kind of okay
to allow the chips to fall where they
may
and we shouldn't do anything to upset
the apple cart particularly if the
current apple cart and its distribution
of apples has been so good to me in mind
that's pretty depressing because you
know i mean i entitled the chapter the
same sky right because we do live under
the same sky you know i mean california
shows like you know the fires are coming
for the gated communities and the
barrios and the farms as well right like
we really can't just
you know kind of hierarchy our way out
of climate catastrophe and by the way
for anyone in the audience who thinks
that we are speaking theoretically about
the fact that you know um zero-sum
racism ends up hurting everyone
we we brought stats all right we brought
[ __ ] stats are you ready for this
we've got stats
we've got infographics and we've got
stats u.s output would have been 2.6
trillion dollars greater if only the gap
between white men and everyone else were
closed
if america
had adopted policies to close the white
black economic gap just 20 years ago and
that that time when you know rain was
listening to to rush limbaugh
the gdp today
would be 16 trillion dollars higher this
isn't theoretical right i mean this is
it's just it's it's flat out money that
we're that we're leaving on the table
shooting ourselves on the foot cutting
off our nose whatever stupid cliche you
want to use for it just because we're
like yeah but i mean we don't want black
and brown people to well i brought up i
brought up healthcare before so
universal healthcare was proposed by
truman in 1947 racist red baiting led by
southern segregationists
kept the proposal from getting off the
ground because they feared that federal
involvement in health care
might lead to federal action against
what yes you guessed it
racial
justice injustice and segregation
so imagine our country if we had had
universal health care it could have all
been scandinavian
i i that that doesn't rain but multiple
racial scandinavians but that's the
point right i mean you know i i always
felt this way when people would compare
us to denmark and say why do they have
you know universal health care and 28
000 days of parental leave and you know
all of this stuff and it's like what's
everybody feels like they're on the same
team you know and they genetically
actually kind of are dude i never
thought about this this is actually a
very interesting point that
when you're in the sort of you know like
norwegian countries that we all like
look at as the
the sort of symbol of progressive
you know fantasy
you're right they're all white so zero
some game doesn't there aren't enough
people to be like yeah but if we all
have universal healthcare then the black
person would too because there ain't no
black people
right
that's right i'm exaggerating but you're
getting the point so this brings this
whole conversation around all right here
we go the reason
uh that we responded so strongly to your
book was there are many books about
racism out there many many and
um and yes racism is horrible and
there's story after story and it is it
is
ungodly and horrific and a cancer upon
our our nation your book is so
crystalline clear
that one of the fundamental issues with
racism is that white people again are
shooting themselves in the foot
economically that everyone has been
woefully
hurt
by
uh by racism
you state that uh usually when racism
bumps up against the pocketbook that the
pocketbook wins but in this case
that's not the case the pocketbook
didn't win racism won but how
do we turn this heather how do we fix
racism is it the fact that we've tried
everything else we've talked to white
people about how much it hurts and
showed them case after case of injustice
in case of case after case of
systematized police brutality etc on and
on and on and on
do we educate uh white folk about the
fact that listen this is holding you
back economically um or is is there
something else what is to be done
um with your
really
kind of clear and practical thesis that
we would all
be so much better off without racism
yeah fix racism for us heather yeah and
we gotta wrap this up so yeah yeah
running a little bit short just a little
long that's a little just just so
i kind of feel like i've run my lap on
this and i would love for the white
people to take up the baton i don't
think it's actually my job
to take this one over the finish line i
didn't start this race i'm just trying
to keep it moving you know um
okay so i i will answer this question by
telling a story
that gives me hope that is for me a
touchstone um and it's a story of a
young woman named bridget
who
is you know many ways sort of a
quintessential white working class
would-be trump voter i don't know if she
ever voted for trump but i wouldn't be
surprised
she uh lives in kansas city she's a
minimum wage worker three kids
um and she
is somebody i met because of
her work on the fight for 15 and a union
fight for 15 an hour
and she describes her life as one in
which she totally believed that kind of
anti-immigrant they're stealing our jobs
they're not paying taxes some of the
like anti-black you know they're
committing so many crimes stuff it was
what her family taught her
and she was also making 7 25 an hour and
she never thought
that they would that you know
her employer would pay her 15 an hour
she thought it was a crazy demand that
the fight for 15 campaign was making but
she went to the first organizing meeting
anyway and it was there that she
saw a latina woman stand up and tell her
story
of having three kids in a two-bedroom
apartment with bad plumbing and feeling
trapped and like there was nowhere to go
in her life and bridgette told me i saw
myself in her
and she said it was it was through that
through seeing myself and my
life reflected in the life of a brown
woman
that she realized and it was through
sort of subsequent organizing for
something that they that united them um
the need to ha you know escape poverty
wages or mick poverty as they called it
in kansas city
that it wasn't a matter of us versus
them she told me she said for as long
for us to come up they've got to come up
to because as long as we're divided she
told me we're conquered
and
bridget's transformation
that was born in common struggle right
by linking arms with somebody who
doesn't have exactly the same life story
right in fact you know the latina woman
was gonna be worried that somebody in
her family might be deported at any time
right and have a layer of other
um
you know challenge in her life and yet
the fundamental human desire for
something better in your family for your
family the desire to not leave your
family in the morning and come back
still without enough money to feed them
that desire is so human
it is so the reason why we have poverty
wages today is so connected to the fact
that our first minimum wage was zero
right and now it's 7.25 right you have a
plantation economy that
says we can steal labor from people and
take all of the rewards of their work we
the elite and and in many ways you know
we're just
making baby steps out of that general
ethos and so
bridget understands now
how her fate is tied up in the fates of
black and brown workers how
people like you know the sort of
restaurant lobby and everything are are
trying to pit them against each other to
keep them divided about how trump
and really the whole as she told me like
the whole point of this movement in many
ways
is for white workers to realize that
racism is bad for them too because it
keeps them divided from their brown and
black brothers and sisters and that's
the lie that trump is telling
so i think about bridget and the
transformation that she had and the way
that she was able to go from
feeling like she was totally trapped to
being one of the leaders of a movement
that has spanned the globe to combat
poverty on the job
and i think
yeah we can do this this this idea of of
cross-racial solidarity of having the
backs of people who are not exactly like
you but share some common struggle
across lines of race is is the most
exciting
and i think powerful phenomenon in our
society and it is happening more and
more and more despite the noise
and i i'm hopeful because of it
so
i think that's i mean it's a it's an
amazing wonderful beautiful story and it
proves the the fundamental truth that
um data
knowledge these things don't change
people's minds relationships change
people's minds and i never get tired of
saying this that bigotry is not the
result of ignorance that bigotry is the
result of fear and fear is impervious to
data or information that fear can only
be tackled through relationships
yeah okay
but we're talking about hundreds of
millions of of people who are playing
this zero-sum game
and
part of it
part of it is like i think back to the
i think back to like you know the civil
rights movement that a lot of the things
that you know some of the lot of the
progressive policies that that people
um were advancing during that time uh
were
re rejected because
people saw black and white people
together you know holding hands and
asking for for basic freedoms and and
civil rights
and
so i it's you know i'm stuck in this
thing where it's like okay part of me
thinks okay if if all of this has to do
with the fact that you know uh
the zero sums racism has forced us to
kind of uh destroy uh the broader
goods
to
drain the pools then the answer is to
refill the pools right and make sure
that people understand the benefits the
economic benefits of policies that do
actually um help
people of color except that we've
already talked about the fact that
psychologically speaking there is
something in the mind that makes you
instantly think to yourself
if this person who is not me who is kind
of how i define myself as a as a
negative pole um if that person succeeds
then i necessarily uh i am not going to
succeed or i'm going to actually like be
be damaged by it some way okay well that
that drives me crazy okay well what
about how about this idea then what
about we just never ever talk about race
ever again right like we we de-racialize
everything like we health we want health
care for everyone okay don't mention
that it might help black people too
right uh we want climate climate uh
change proposals like nobody mentioned
that it might actually help brown and
black people and then maybe we'll get
white people to accept it but that
doesn't sound right either and i don't
even think it works so it's like [ __ ]
at the policy level not at the relation
level
the relation level you're right like
what else are you gonna do you have to
actually get people
to see
themselves in the other
but at the policy level how do we get
the country
to rally around things that are
objectively
quantifiably good for all of us
without instantly falling into the
zero-sum racism trap i'm really stunned
and inspired by what you just said and
it brings me to my final
question uh you worked for years on this
book obviously this book is like the
culmination of your life's work really
um yeah is did writing it make you more
optimistic that there is a path forward
or more pessimistic about our country's
future
you know
i learned a lot i'm surprised by a lot
in writing the some of us
i
didn't actually think
that i would find the fingerprints of
racism around so many issues so many
policy areas
just how pervasive it would be yeah
that that racism was the sort of thread
connecting these issues from
why workers aren't paid enough to why we
aren't acting strongly on climate change
to you know
why our democracy is so corrupt but
ultimately the effect for me of seeing
that thread across so many issues was
that it it felt at the end kind of
easier to make progress on each of them
if we just
pull the thread right and that progress
on each of those issues which on their
own can feel kind of like mind-bendingly
complex and difficult if you take each
challenge on its own and try to
not see the racial dynamics there in our
politics and our policy making
so it's like if we pull that common
thread
solutions become
a lot closer at hand
and so i did leave
you know
the writing the final the final
words which i did after the election in
november um
feeling more optimistic that
if this is a kind of rosetta stone for
for seeing our politics in a new way
that it makes it simpler it's easier to
understand and and hopefully easier to
move forward
that's actually a brilliant and dare i
say existential
thought
that when you recognize
that so many of these issues that are
plaguing our world
actually have at their heart
the problem of racism
it actually makes it weirdly
easier to confront all these
giant issues because deal with the core
the central issue
yeah
and if we can pull that thread and
unravel racism and see it at be as being
at the core of so many other
you know world crippling issues um
that goes to that essential otherness
that racism is about about
you know alienating the other and making
ourselves separate from one another and
not
united as a human species sharing a
biosphere and those you're right reza
and and and heather the
the path does become more clear if we if
we really shine a light on this one
issue
um
there's there's a way forward around
you know
economics and poverty and environment
and and health care and mental health
and so many of these other you know
crippling horrible issues that the world
is dealing with
you know there there may be a way out
yeah
i'd like to think so i mean here we
thought you were just going to solve
racism turns out you solved everything
thank you you solved all the world's
problems not just racism
thank you come
dear listeners
speaking of
terrible transition it's time for the
lightning round
all right questions this is how this
works is uh we're gonna ask you a few of
just life's big questions and then you
just answer with the first thing that
comes to your mind
okay all right ready here we go
take it away brain
okay
uh lightning round when do you heather
feel most connected with the universe
uh when i was nursing my son i did feel
the most connected with the universe
what's one habit that you have that
you're actually proud of
uh talking to strangers and giving money
to people who ask it on the floor on the
street
do you give money to people that you're
doing podcasts with
cash up cash at me bro
i think men mo me you're doing okay rain
what is one skill
that you wish you had
i wish i could sing
like really saying
what book changed your life
the color purple
and why i mean i suppose we should
um it was the first story that i
couldn't stop thinking about
that followed me everywhere and i was
really young it's kind of an adult story
and i read it when i was really young um
but it was just the first time i saw
characters like me like black girls
and and truly loved them and just
couldn't stop thinking about them
describe your soul in 10 words or less
my soul is
dinner parties
babies
cats
shooting stars and
expired milk
one of these kids is not like the other
good god okay all right name something
that most people like but that you can't
stand
flan
oh god no who likes flan
flan like half the global population i
know rayne likes i love flan
but i will tell you something i don't
like how flan makes my mouth feel
there's no there's no difference between
good flan and bad flaw that's just so
true
do you know what i mean like you can go
into like a a crappy puerto rican deli
and they have like flan to go in a
little foil a capsule you know in in new
york city and you can eat it with a
spoon it's going to taste the same as
like the fanciest flan at the most you
know at the fanciest south american
restaurant in los angeles
exactly i would say this is the most
amount of times that the word flon has
been said in a podcast
how do we solve heather how do we solve
the flan crisis
is it racism that gives flan its mouth
feel
that by feature when it all goes back to
racism
and finally
what is your life's biggest question
can we get there in time can we do it in
time
i love that not can we get there but can
we do it in time heather mcgee
uh you know i'm nuts about you uh thank
you so much for joining us uh this is um
i mean we don't need to sing the praises
of this book everybody else is already
singing the praises of this book huge uh
bestseller and um i think it's just
provided at least for us a new framework
for
how to think not just about racism but
about all
our social problems and i'm so grateful
to
call you my friend
and and speaking of that friendship one
thing i noticed about your book heather
there were a lot of amazing
authors that were blurbed
on your book i didn't see reza's
name there anywhere
i didn't see
the reza aslan quote i
some of us i just don't know how this
friendship
how strong this friendship really is i
guess i really
i don't know friends don't ask friends
to blurb you know that
that's crossing a line heather mcgee
thank you so much for solving not only
racism but all of the world's problems
we love you so much thank you for your
time thank you
thank you guys i love this
i'll tell you what i loved about that
conversation rain okay go is that and
we've done you know we've done dozens of
these conversations where it's like
here's a problem and it's an endemic
problem and okay so how do we fix it and
then the person says oh we fix it by you
know loving each other and holding hands
or we fix it by changing the way that we
think about x y and z
but
what heather said at the end of that
conversation about like
how do we get people
to
remove the zero-sum racism mentality and
actually
support things that are
to everyone's benefit and also to racial
minorities benefit
the way that you do that is by appealing
to something that i think
is an even deeper impulse
than racism
and that's this notion that someone out
there is like trying to get you that
someone that that you know that there's
a like a greedy
corporation you know these like rich
folk
they're they're making this an issue of
race and they're doing it to pick your
pockets
and and and don't fall for it
and
i i don't know about you but that that
kind of [ __ ] always works for me like
whenever someone's like oh they're
they're trying to pull the wool over
your eyes don't let them i always get
energized by that and it seems like such
an obvious
thing to do right to just be like
this isn't about race
it they're making it about race because
they want to pick your pockets that's
what this is about like that to me
that works
about 80 percent of democrats
and almost 60 percent of republicans are
in favor of taxing the super rich
uh in order to fund social programs so
this is actually an item of unity so
that's right it kind of goes hand in
hand with that i love that idea i like
that there are there are giant
elite corporate interests
that want to continue to foment
racism and turn everything into a racist
diatribe in order to keep the people
down and to keep you all poorer
um yeah so maybe pocketbook can trump
racism after all
it might i mean it seems like a better
better plan than
talking about racial justice messaging
that doesn't work we talked about why
that doesn't work it actually turns
people off yeah
it the colorblind message which i've
always this isn't about race every
[ __ ] thing's about race and by the
way like read heather's book
everything's about race
but yeah you said it right like you know
this is all a scam
that
these rich corporations are pulling
right uh yeah this is a pr we're going
to watch this actually take place here
when we start talking about taxing the
rich you're going to hear the koch
brothers well the koch brother now say
um
say something to the effect of oh this
is so you know so that
we can give more welfare to poor people
by which he means black and brown people
right and when that message starts our
message has to be
this is a scam
it does it does play into the worst of
human instincts which is like mistrust
and conspiracy and protecting what's
mine and i gotta use it to our advantage
maybe we leverage it to our advantage
until humanity gradually eventually
matures yes and sees us all as one
beautiful
human family holding hands in the
sunlight holding balloons but until then
thank you heather mcgee for uh giving us
a path forward and diving deep with the
metaphysical milkshake team
milkshakers
welcome
uh as you know
sometimes we bring guests onto the show
to ask their life's big questions
to discuss these topics with them
here's how you can reach us you can
reach us on social media and uh tweet at
us instagram at us
and we'll look you up and hunt you down
or leave a review on apple podcasts with
your life's big question and we will
track you down and bring you on the show
we're very lucky today to have a a guest
a fan a listener
peter is on the show hi peter how are
you doing
i'm good nice to meet you where are you
are you calling from
west hollywood
well i used to live in west hollywood
yeah back in my younger and my younger
sexier days
you gotta be like young and sexy to live
in west hollywood and and you peter you
look young and spend fairly sexy i have
to say thank you very much i appreciate
that yeah i
my parents first house was in west
hollywood but it's nice
going back here like after college nice
all right so your college grad what
brings you to the show what is your what
is your question what can we discuss
with you
yeah so i'm a writer and i'm wondering
if you think it's possible to create
something that's not influenced by your
life or background or do you think that
everything we create stems from our own
personalities and individual life
experiences oh do i have a lot to say
about this oh i bet we've got a writing
professor
to say about this yeah
well look peter i mean the oldest adage
in writing is right what you know right
people say this all the time right what
you know right what you know and it's
true except that
it's misunderstood
i think the problem is that people think
write what you know means write only
about things that you know about
but that's not what we mean when we say
write what you know
right what you know
means
mine
the depths of your experience
to create
universal emotions
right like what i always tell my
students is
individual experience
universal emotions
so
you know you may not uh know what it's
like to you know be an astronaut okay so
it's like oh well am i not allowed to
write a
character who's an astronaut well of
course you are because you know what
it's like to be scared you know what
it's like to be lonely you know what
it's like to
you know uh
be exhilarated you know you know what
it's like to be floating 5000 miles
above the earth in orbit
and so
write what you know
isn't about your experiences it's about
your emotions
that's that's what i always try to re
remind people you know like you can
write you can make your protagonist be
anybody
that you want it to be but you have to
instill your own emotions into that
character in order to make them real but
they don't have to be literally you
they just have to
have your emotions because your emotions
one of the greatest qualities that we
have as human beings is imagination and
some of my greatest
favorite works of fiction
alice in wonderland
dante's inferno
okay truth be told i never read that one
um
stephen king's the stand you know uh 100
years of solitude these are greatly
imaginative magical books um
that i'm so glad the author undertook
and didn't feel that
they could only write abject realism as
a style
because that's what they know so you can
only write about a college grad living
in west hollywood
um but i think you're exactly right roza
what about you peter what kind of stuff
are you writing what are you working on
and how are you bumping up against this
yeah so
um
so i went to emerson and emerson has a
campus
in hollywood on sunset and my last
semester like right before covet
happened
i took a class about
writing female characters in horror
movies
and we got to read a lot of horror
scripts and
i loved that class and we also got to
write the first act of a horror feature
which was a lot of fun so i've been
working on that script a lot the last
two years peter how's emerson's football
team doing this year
um they're great they're undefeated this
year oh fabulous great peter good luck
with your writing um uh i love that
assignment to to write a different
gender than yourself and uh to to push
those boundaries i think that's that's
exciting and and cool and a very
interesting question and reza that was a
terrific answer i actually learned
something today from you believe it or
not
yeah
that's so rare yeah so put that in your
book
and smoke it thank you peter
so do you want more of these life's big
questions find us on social at reza
aslan and at rayne wilson and at
metaphysical milkshake and let us know
your life's big questions we just might
explore them on a future episode
and always remember to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts or wherever else you may listen
to your podcast and if you like to see
people's lips move while they're having
conversations you can watch us on
youtube so subscribe to the metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel and watch our
full episodes every week all right see
you next week and don't be racist
don't be a racist jerk
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
and if you can say the poor white people
i mean i mean i know you're not a coal
miner
oh oh you know uh jethro
i feel like that was racist too that was
that racist calling you yeah okay uh you
see
the sea
you see what i'm up against heather
see oh well let's make fun of the people
we'll call him jethro
why isn't his name phil
evan evan i feel like most white people
are named
let's continue
this hypothetical poor white male is
named evan
evan and i think jethro is a beautiful
name
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you